es passierte während einer debatte über
den dreck cit im britischen unterhaus
entnommen
der konservative politiker kennen clark
am dienstag gerade eine längere rede
über die möglichen auswirkungen des
britischen austritt aus der eu sein
parteikollege desmonds wayne unter dem
aber offenbar nicht so richtig voll auf
den bildern des parlaments fernsehens
ist zu sehen wie swain im rücken des
redners zur seite kippt es sieht so aus
als ob der politiker schlafen würde als
der reporter wird schreckt swain kurz
auf um dann scheinbar wieder
einzuknicken
schließlich kommt der schläfrige
abgeordnete dann aber doch zur besinnung
und das mit einem lächeln auf den lippen